In the early years of the North American League Championship Series players and organizations
banded together to legitimize competitive
gaming as a mainstream spectacle.
Now, the NA LCS is big business.
It costs millions to field a team on that stage, and more than ever the pressure is on players to perform.
Rosters are constantly in flux as teams import international talent in the pursuit of winning
an NA LCS Championship.
Organizations need franchise players that they can build an identity and culture around.
A player to lead their team for years to come.
A player who won’t waver when a new patch drops or new players are inserted into the starting lineup.
A player that they can count on to hold a team together.
A player like Sneaky.
"What the f*** is up, professional maid streamer here."
(Casting)
Zachary "Sneaky" Scuderi was born in Winter Springs, Florida, and played competitive World of Warcraft
before League of Legends was released.
"I grew up in Orlando before I moved out to California to pursue my career."
"My friends that got me into League, we kinda just played all the games together, we started off with WoW."
"Which got us into DotA, and that's how I started with Heroes of Newerth, and moved into League of Legends
through that."
Sneaky started his competitive LoL career in 2012 with Absolute Gaming
and like a lot of small tournament teams from that era, they only lasted about four months together.
Sneaky then started his own team called Pulse Gaming with Kenikth, Onionbagel, Kevin and Support Daddy.
Pulse, failed to qualify for 2013 LCS summer promotional tournaments at the MLG and IPL
qualifier events they competed in and as the team constantly shuffled their roster,
Sneaky began to lose confidence in their ability to make it to the LCS.
"It's actually really saddening realizing that, because you actually realize that you're not very good as a team."
"I remember our preparation was like, alright go look up these guys solo queues."
"Whatever, alright let's go. Nothing past that, there was no notebook to write down pick bans, what their plan is."
"It was just, pick whatever you feel like basically."
So in April 2013 Sneaky joined Quantic gaming.
Quantic had previously played under the Cloud9 banner without Sneaky during the promotional
tournament for the inaugural LCS split in Spring 2013 but were subsequently dropped by the organization
after they failed to qualify.
The new Sneaky-empowered Quantic lineup — which also featured Hai, Balls, Meteos and LemonNation
— managed to qualify for the LCS Summer 2013 split and re-joined the Cloud9 organization
The classic C9 roster, that became one to the cornerstones of the LCS and paved
the way for the macro gameplay in North America we know today was born.
"And they were the most impressive team in the promotion tournament including Dignitas and CLG
who had been demoted there, they steamrolled compLexity three games to none to earn their spot in the
LCS."
Cloud9 was nothing short of dominant in their first LCS split.
The team posted a 25-3 record during the regular season and rolled through the playoffs without
dropping a single match.
(Casting)
To this day, that record still puts 2013 C9 as one of the most dominating teams in NA LCS history.
During that first split, Sneaky left his mark on the league.
He led all AD Carries with a 6.96 KDA and cleaned up on Ashe, with which he posted a whopping 11-0 record.
(Casting)
Cloud9 qualified for the Season 3 World Championship.
But despite earning a first-round bye, C9 were eliminated by the tournament’s top EU seed.
(Casting)
C9 and Sneaky continued their dominance into 2014 where they once again won the split.
And Sneaky once again sat atop the KDA leaderboard not just for ADC but across all five positions.
When you look at the numbers, you could make a case for Sneaky being NA’s best ADC in
almost any LCS split he’s played in.
"Yeah Sneaky's always been top tier North American AD Carry."
"Sneaky was so consistent for this team, he just shows up every single day."
Much like C9, he’s the model of consistency.
C9 and Sneaky seemed to understand macro play much quicker than the rest of league
and Sneaky credits a lot of their success to this.
(Casting)
They were able to play as a team all over the map,
and use Hai’s shotcalling and their overall game knowledge to play around Sneaky and snowball games.
(Casting)
Between splits in 2014, C9 attended the international all-star event without their mid laner Hai,
who was sidelined with a collapsed lung.
They went 3-1 in the Group Stage, only losing to Faker’s SK Telecom.
They would advance through groups, where they were dispatched by one of the Chinese representatives,
OMG Gaming.
(Casting)
Cloud9 put NA on the map, making it clear that the region should not be overlooked internationally
In Summer 2014 Sneaky and Cloud9 were met with real competition for the first time since they’d joined the LCS.
"More than ever Cloud9 may not be the first place team. CLG's looking very strong, we also don't know LMQ."
"How good are they, how bad are they?"
"Yeah I think the team that has benefitted the most from these roster changes is C9."
It was clear that the league was shifting as organizations were looking to improve their results
by importing players and shuffling their rosters.
But C9, ever the model of consistency, still fielded the same roster as their inaugural split.
Cloud9 finished the split tied for first place with LMQ — an all Chinese imported roster.
They then lost the Summer Finals to Team SoloMid who were playing their second split with European
superstar Bjergsen.
(Casting)
After the Summer Finals, it was time for Worlds again. Where Cloud9 would make North American history.
Cloud9 went 4-2 in their Worlds Group stage and met Korean powerhouse Samsung Blue in the quarterfinals.
(Casting)
Cloud9 lost that series 3-1 but became the first NA team in the LCS era to take a game
off of a Korean team at a major international tournament.
Sneaky was a driving force in the series, showing that he could compete alongside game’s best AD Carries
(Casting)
Cloud9 rode the momentum they had from Worlds
into another post-season event at IEM San Jose, where Cloud9 and particularly Sneaky shined.
(Casting)
Their bursts of success on the international stage aside, the transition between Summer 2014
and the 2015 LCS season was certainly a changing of the guard for Sneaky and Cloud9.
They simply weren’t the best anymore, Team SoloMid had knocked them off their pedestal
and they weren’t going to let them take it back anytime soon.
Cloud9 went 12-6 in the 2015 Spring Split, rebounding after a shaky first two weeks.
They went into the playoffs with a first round bye and were second place overall behind TSM.
But once again, they weren’t able to defeat
Bjergsen and co. in the finals.
"Speaking of wins for Team SoloMid, the Nexus falls, and Team SoloMid are the 2015 North American
League of Legends Championship Series Spring Split Champions."
Despite the veil of dominance being lifted from his team, Sneaky had stayed on course.
He continued to show that he was the ADC to beat in the TSM and C9 rivalry.
(Casting)
Sneaky once again led all AD carries in KDA, and died less the any other bot lane marksman.
Hai was removed from the mid lane prior to the summer season and replaced by Jensen, who was then known as
Incarnati0n,
a young European playmaker whose competitive
lifetime ban was recently lifted.
"I don't think the roster change was ever initially brought up by any of the players."
"I think it was just Jack looking out for us."
"No one really wanted to go out of our way to say, hey I think we need to change a player out here."
As the 2015 Summer Split started, Cloud9 looked like a shadow of their former self.
"The worst trend though was Cloud9 even after beating TSM with the first game of the split,
Now sits at one and three,"
(Casting)
"And Cloud9 once again find themselves on the short end of the stick here after actually
playing a strong game."
"But not finding the advantage that pushes them to the win just yet."
"There's a lot of growing to do for this new Cloud9 squad with Incarnati0n instead of Hai."
Despite the fact the Sneaky was still making big plays in the bot lane, the team went 6-12
during the split, their worst record ever, and missed the playoffs for the first time in franchise history.
"I'd say I definitely have thought of it more about like, not being on Cloud9."
"Just because we're in such a bad spot right now."
After the split, Sneaky did his best to show that what remained of the old-guard C9 roster could still compete.
"Well I think the only ever time that it was talked about leaving, that was kind of a Riot pushed agenda."
"I never really said it. It was just like, "You guys are doing terribly Sneaky, what would think about joining a
different team." And I'm like, "Yeah we're like 8th place LCS right now.""
They played in a regional finals gauntlet to try and secure the third NA birth in Worlds that year.
C9 was coming off one of their worst LCS performances ever, but the gauntlet gave them a chance
to remain a beacon for North America on the international stage.
"To be able to bring it back and actually go to Worlds would be amazing for us considering our
pretty terrible season."
"As strange as it sounds. Call Cloud9 a Cinderella story, they could go on a miracle run to secure their third
consecutive appearance at Worlds."
(Casting)
Not only did C9 win the regional qualifier and get a spot at Worlds,
but Sneaky dominated.
(Casting)
To the surprise of most, Cloud9 dominated the first week of Worlds, going a perfect
3-0 against some of the best teams in the world
(Casting)
Prior to the 2016 LCS season C9’s persistence to keep much of their lineup together caught up to them.
Teams like Immortals were boasting impressive imported talent in the likes of Huni and Reignover
and just being consistent wasn’t going to be enough for C9.
Even their biggest rival TSM were making the changes necessary to stay on top,
bringing in Doublelift, Yellowstar and Svenskeren.
C9 made a few changes as well to try to keep up with the quickly shifting NA LCS.
LemonNation had retired and C9 added both jungler Rush and support player BunnyFuFu to their roster.
Bunny split time with Hai in the bot lane as the organization was trying to reshape
the roster around Sneaky.
"Well it's definitely a different atmosphere when we have Bunny in the team because Hai is the super shotcaller
where he's trying to always talk, but when we have Bunny on the team. It's not necessarily a bad thing but he's like
A bit less talkative, like less commanding."
And then Rush kind of like takes over a little bit of the role, so it's like shared between him and Bunny."
The 2016 Spring Split was just as lacklustre as their Worlds run.
They finished third in NA during the split and lost to TSM in the playoffs again.
It was at the end of this split that Cloud9 took the rebuilding plan to a new level.
They shuffled around their LCS roster with their challenger team.
Impact in the top lane, Meteos in the jungle, Jensen was now full-time in the mid lane,
Sneaky at AD Carry as always and Bunny FuFu and newcomer Smoothie split time in the support role.
During that year, C9 matched their 12-6 record from spring, making it back to the finals
for the first time in three splits.
Sneaky finished second behind Doublelift in KDA and had an impressive split,
acting as a stabilizing presence for a roster that was just learning how to play around each other.
But once again, there they were defeated by TSM.
(Casting)
C9 competed at Worlds again after the season to another quarterfinals exit.
They had overhauled the majority of their roster, but still weren’t getting the championship
results they were looking for.
Meteos left the team and Contractz was called up to fill the hole in the Jungle for Spring 2017
"I think we'll be pretty ready for this spring split, it's pretty important to us."
"I think it's gonna be a pretty big lead into summer and if we can perform now which we should be able to
from our practice then it'll really help us out a lot."
Just as the split was set to begin, Sneaky was the only member of the original Cloud9 left standing.
"Does it feel weird thinking about that like, you are the original, you're the only one left."
"Do you get lonely?"
"Yeah, okay I don't know about lonely but."
"I definitely kind of think about that a little bit more as of recently. I was playing against Meteos in scrims.
And we were winning one of the games really hard, I started feeling really sad for Meteos,
I was just like, I want to see him do well."
But, even though major changes had finally come to one of the LCS’ original powerhouses,
the results were the same.
This new-look Cloud9 went 14-4 in the regular season, only to lose another playoff final to TSM.
(Casting)
In a lot of ways both Cloud9 and Sneaky have followed the same enigmatic path through their time in the LCS.
They’re always good, always in the conversation amongst NA’s best.
But it had been a while since they sat atop the standings.
Cloud9 went from the shining star of the NA LCS to the leagues to its perennial second-fiddle.
They rallied back from a slow start in 2017 summer to make the playoffs, only to be ousted
in the quarterfinals by Dignitas.
Now we’ve recently seen their 2018 run come to an end in similar fashion.
They looked impressive for the majority of the first half of the split, but faltered a little
heading into playoffs to finish 12-8.
Team Liquid then knocked them out of the playoffs in the quarterfinals for the second time in a row.
Doublelift getting the better of Sneaky once again, this time in another uniform.
Sneaky had a solid year, but it just hasn’t
been good enough since as far back as Spring 2014.
"And they're the North American Champions."
Throughout his career with Cloud9 Sneaky’s stream has always been a major part of his
identity as a player.
Just like on the rift, Sneaky’s stream has been consistent ever since he began his career in the LCS.
It’s on-stream where he garnered his reputation as a bit of a memer.
(Stream)
Sneaky’s always good for a few dozen “feelsgoodmans” a week on stream.
He’s always laid back and joking around with his chat.
(Stream)
His streams are just like his playing career.
Not always making headlines, not breaking viewership records.
But always there, always entertaining and always worth your attention.
(Throws pizza)
Sneaky streams about three or four times a week even during the season.
While comparable names like Doublelift or Bjergsen can be a little more streaky, sometimes
taking weeks off at a time.
Sneaky most recently made headlines for his on-stream Lux cosplay,
a long-term sub goal that drew attention from all over the esports world.
Streaming often allows us a little look into the lives of pro players.
Whether it’s Bjergsen laser focus or Doublelift’s constant trash talk.
The biggest takeaway from what you see from Sneaky on-stream is the the kind of un-shakeable
attitude he exudes on the LCS stage.
No matter just how much his chat is flaming him.
He’s always got the same nonchalant attitude, and then hits them with a “feelsbadman.”
We’ve arrived in an LCS world where organizations are franchised for the long-term, and consistency
In this new world, Sneaky is the image of
the consummate professional.
But amidst another “just okay” split, Sneaky has stood still.
There’s a lot of question marks surrounding
C9 going forward.
But there’s one thing we can likely count on.
Sneaky will hold down the bot lane for C9.
And he'll continue to be the cornerstone that holds this iconic franchise together.
"I want to keep playing professionally as long as I can. I don't think there's ever a stopping point.
So I'm not going to stop at five years from now, I'm just going to keep on going,
because there's nothing else I'd rather do."
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.